darüber wird diskutiert dieses dicke
diese decke beschlussvorlage genau so
dick wie sie offenbar in den letzten
monaten auch schon immer wieder war was
wir natürlich hoffen ist normalität was
wir bekommen das ist allerdings nicht
ganz so normal dass sich weitere
beschlüsse und darüber sprechen können
wir mit unserem bild vize paul
ronzheimer paul gibt's kleine irgendwas
neues schon nein der stand von gestern
abend also dieser stand den wir über
bild exklusiv vermeldet haben daher hat
sich stand jetzt nichts verändert es
wird vorbesprechung geben vor dem 12 30
vor der 12 30 staaten im video
schaltkonferenz der bundeskanzlerin mit
dabei live im raum sozusagen mit dabei
markus söder und der chef der
ministerpräsidenten zu diesem zeitpunkt
also der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
dem regierenden bürgermeister herrn
müller in berlin aber was wir sagen
können und das was wir hier sehen das
hat klaus stöhr gerade in einem
interview mit uns ein bisschen als
paralleluniversum beschrieben und ich
glaube das trifft es ganz gut denn
während die menschen dort draußen
darüber nachdenken wann sie endlich ein
freedom day vielleicht wie in
großbritannien oder wie in dänemark am
ersten oktober haben geht es hier weiter
mit maßnahmen und auch ich habe so ein
bisschen ein déjà vu muss ich sagen denn
diese dieser dieser entwurf der sieht
auch rein haptisch natürlich genau so
aus wie das was wir in den vergangenen
monaten im vergangenen anderthalb jahren
erlebt haben es setzt sich nicht davon
ab viele wichtige werte sind noch nicht
ergänzt worden also die frage ist was
gilt ab wann wirklich da geht es vor
allem um die frage was mit den nicht
geimpften passiert ich stelle mir vor
allem die frage was ist mit den schulen
also wird es am ende dann weitere masten
pflicht wie es jetzt aussieht natürlich
in den schulen geben die verlängerung
was bedeutet das für den wechsel
unterricht können wir da wirklich sicher
gehen und da wird es noch ordentlich
streit geben zwischen den
ministerpräsidenten und der
bundeskanzlerin ja viele fragen und wir
schon einmal in dieses déjà vu parallel
universums papier ein was da genau steht
und gucken mal zum thema masken pflicht
das ist ja ein sondern debatte wir alle
fragen uns wann bis wann müssen wir die
masken auftragen und in dem papier heißt
es eben um einen bestmöglichen
infektionsschutz
zu gewährleisten gelten weiter die basis
schutzmaßnahmen für die gesamte
bevölkerung das heißt das tragen
medizinischer schutzmasken im
einzelhandel und im öffentlichen
personal verkehr bleibt wichtig und
daher für die gesamte bevölkerung
verbindlich vorgeschrieben das ist
insofern absurd man fragt sich wenn wir
oder wenn ich geimpft bin also wie groß
ist dann wirklich noch die gefahr was
ist mit meiner mit meinen
freiheitsrechten in dem moment warum
muss ich dann die maske weitertragen wer
ist die argumentation ja gut du kannst
ja als geimpfter auch diejenigen
gefährden die nicht geimpft sind aber es
ist eine klare weitere
freiheitseinschränkung in anderen
ländern wir haben in österreich
gesprochen
wenn wir über die niederlande gesprochen
da ist zum beispiel im einzelhandel die
masten pflicht schon komplett gefallen
und man hatte im vorfeld dieser debatte
schon das gefühl dass einzelne
ministerpräsidenten versucht haben in
richtung mehr freiheit zu drängen aber
insbesondere die kanzlerin insbesondere
der kanzleramtsminister helge braun dass
die weiterhin zu dem kurs stehen denen
sie in den letzten anderthalb jahren
verfolgt haben die kanzlerin will jetzt
hier in den letzten monaten im september
in der september ist war da muss sie
vielleicht noch je nach
koalitionsgesprächen bis oktober
november regieren da will sie das nicht
riskieren sie bleibt bei dem was sie
gesagt hat und will als die kanzlerin in
die geschichte einigen offenbar die
strikt und aus ihrer sicht vorsichtig
geblieben ist die aber auch und das muss
man auch ganz klar sagen die
freiheitsrechte der bürger für eine sehr
lange zeit mit einschränkt eingeschränkt
hat und weiter einschränken will
ja und unflexibel ist denn wir haben
eine ganz neue lage das ist es steht nun
mal fest also wir sind jeder zweite
deutsche ist laut dem rk ii durchgeimpft
mittlerweile aber lasst uns auf ein
weiteres einen weiteren punkt dieses
papiers schauen das thema feiern nämlich
eine sache die glaube ich sehr viele
menschen sehr sehr gerne tun und da
sieht es zappenduster aus muss man sagen
also veranstaltungen feiern bars und
clubs sind die bereiche die mit einem
besonders hohen risiko für mehrfach
ansteckungen verbunden sind die länder
und kommunen werden weiterhin durch
einschränkende regelungen oder
situationsbezogene entscheidungen im
einzelfall die zulässige teilnehmerzahl
und dem zugang begrenzen wo dies
erforderlich ist es wieder wahnsinnig
kompliziert geschrieben paul aber heißt
eigentlich ja es heißt dass es so weiter
geht wie wir es bislang kennen
und mir macht das so ein bisschen diese
sprache angst weil diese sprache auch da
ein déjà vu ergibt das ist ganz klar aus
dem kanzleramt geschrieben man erkennt
die sprache von helge braun wieder in
diesen formulierungen etwas floskelhaft
aber doch sehr strikt sehr maßnahmen
orientiert und man möchte davon nicht
abweichen
das ist die klare regeln wobei man sagen
muss insbesondere die frage was feiern
angeht auch da sind unsere europäischen
nachbarländer unterschiedliche unterwegs
wir haben gehört in den niederlanden
gibt es jetzt eine sperrstunde war das
in die höhe geschossen ist in
großbritannien allerdings da hat der
fremde wo alle papst offen sind wo es
wieder möglich war wonach der
europameisterschaft oder während der
europameisterschaft viele menschen
zusammengekommen sind das hat die zahlen
nicht nach oben getrieben sondern sie
sind leicht abgeflacht also da ist die
frage warum können wir das nicht in
unsere instituts ist im vergleich zu
denen insbesondere in großbritannien gar
nichts wir sind bild und wir liefern dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren